so this is just a quick announcement for
those who've been following me
uh as the channel has been growing um
i decided that i was going to add my
brother matir as a
manager for the for my youtube channel
those of you who have been following me
have seen the interviews that i've done
with him
and uh well it seems that to do that i
had to change the type of account i had
it
something had to be a brand account
anyways that's not important
but in making the change a side effect
which i did not know
at the time was that all of my comments
disappeared and so all of the
engagements that i've had with you guys
in all the videos
uh for the last few months hundreds of
comments are gone and there is no way
to get them back and so now if you go
back into the videos you'll see
all your guys's comments uh which won't
make much sense because the comments
that i've written in between
have disappeared and so yeah the joys of
youtube so hopefully
for now from now on it'll be fine and
this won't happen again
um and so we'll move on
so stay tuned a new video will be coming
soon